ANDREW LITTELL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Andrew Littell.
And it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome
to Google, Simon Winchester.
Mr. Winchester,
welcome to Google.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Thank
you very much, Andrew.
ANDREW LITTELL: I'd
like to start out today
by asking you about your
latest book, "The Men Who
United the States."
What drove you to write
about this particular aspect
of American history?
SIMON WINCHESTER: Well,
I'd become a citizen
on Independence Day.
ANDREW LITTELL: Congratulations.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Thank you
very much, indeed-- in 2011.
And because of that, it
is a very emotional thing
to be inducted into this
great amalgam of people.
And I was very proud and happy.
And because I'd been fascinated
with America ever since I
hitchhiked around it
in 1962, when I was 17.
So once I'd become
a citizen, I thought
I would love to have a
bash at writing a book.
But I didn't really know how to.
I mean it's an enormous subject.
And it's also a
subject which has
been written about by
thousands of people, academics,
and explorers, and journalist.
And it was a question
of trying to write it
in a way that was
fresh and different,
but nonetheless told a story
that I thought was compelling.
And I came up with a variety
of ideas, none of which
initially piqued my interest or,
more importantly, my editor's
interest.
But the fourth one, it
wasn't three is a charm.
It was four is
charm in this case.
I was just ruminating one day
on the name of the country,
the United States of America,
and looking specifically
at this adjective,
"United," and how did
that happen to come about?
Not merely come about, but
to remain a coherent aspect
of this country for
most of its existence,
with obviously the single
exception of the 1960s
and the terrible events
of the Civil War.
Because it occurred to me
that the other great entities
on the world's surface,
Canada let's say,
Russia, Europe, none
of them had seriously
achieved total
and lasting unity.
I mean dear old
Canada, we love it.
But the fact of the
matter is that there
is this great Francophone
block in the middle, Quebec,
which is forever threatening,
sometimes loudly, sometimes
less so, to split the
country into three.
The Soviet Union,
we've seen what's
happened in the aftermath
of the breakup of the Soviet
Union, dozens of little states,
often hostile to one another.
And Europe, where I'm from,
I mean despite the best
efforts of idealists,
politicians, since the 1950s,
we can't really rightly say
that it's achieved total unity.
Well, I made at a serious
level, here's England.
We don't use the euro.
We're at the moment
when thinking
about splitting
apart from Scotland.
That's coming up for
discussion in 18 months or so.
Within Europe itself, I
mean Switzerland is not
a part of the European Union.
If you try and plug your
electric razor in in Stockholm,
you'll need a different plug
from the one you use in Madrid.
And everyone is speaking
in different languages
and there is no common
language in Europe.
And yet America, which is
this great mongrel amalgam
of peoples of every
imaginable ethnic background,
and religious affiliation,
and political viewpoint,
does manage to hang together.
And I thought, let's ruminate
on this word, "united."
And then it was a question
of how to structure a book.
And that was in a way,
the more difficult thing.
But we can talk about that--
ANDREW LITTELL: Sure.
SIMON WINCHESTER: --as we
move along, I dare say.
ANDREW LITTELL: Well, the thing
that immediately, even before I
picked up the book and was
just looking at the title,
I was really captivated by
this idea of regionalism
as a part of being
united and so looking
at the wide variety
of regions that
are represented within
this United States.
And I think it's a very delicate
balance between allowing
differences and regional
characteristics to flourish,
but also being part
of a greater whole.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Well, it is.
The variation that you speak of,
I've become somewhat involved
in a project related
to that as well,
which is for the last 50
years in Madison, Wisconsin,
they've been preparing a
dictionary, which they've
at last finished, which you
probably know about, DARE,
the "Dictionary of
American Regional English.
It's a very long story,
but basically when
it was initiated in
the 1960s by people
that believed there was huge
variation within this country
linguistically
and dialectically,
let's record it before it
all effervesces and America,
everyone speaks
exactly the same,
which hasn't happened of course.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
SIMON WINCHESTER: And
they sent these people
to the furthest
reaches of this country
and what were
called Word Wagons.
And they went down to little
villages in Louisiana,
or up in Alaska, or up in Maine
and found the oldest person
that had lived there for
decades and asked them--
they had a huge
350-page questionnaire.
And it must been a
daunting prospect
to see these two young students
turn up on your doorstep
and ask you the same
questions every time, what
do you call the
insect that bites you
on the neck in the
summertime, what
do you call the strip of grass
between the front of your house
and the curb?
And they built up from this,
this immense dictionary.
It's six volumes.
It was just finished--
ANDREW LITTELL: Wow.
SIMON WINCHESTER: --last year,
which displays majestically
the variation that
you talk about.
So when we drive down the
interstate and we're just
confronted by Walgreen's, and
McDonald's, and everything
looks the same, once you get
off the interstates it really
isn't.
And what you say
is so true that out
of this astonishing variety,
which still exists, nonetheless
connective tissue, which
makes everyone able to say,
I am an American,
which allows me
to say that nowadays
of course, is something
that I wanted to write about.
ANDREW LITTELL: Well, let's
talk about the structure
a little bit.
Because when you talk about
the men who united the states,
it could very easily be a list
of men in alphabetical order,
with very long entries for
some and shorter entries
for another.
But that wouldn't make
very good reading.
And so that the device
or the technique I
think that you've stumbled
upon is really interesting.
And if you could talk
a little about it?
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
I mean you're absolutely right.
I've always maintained
that in writing nonfiction,
there are three
crucial elements.
There's the idea, which is king.
Good writing helps.
But it's not in my view, the
second most important thing.
I think the second
most important thing
is the structure of the book.
You can write lyrically
about a wonderful idea.
But if the structure is off,
the reader will be turned away.
You're absolutely right, I was
preparing a list of the people.
And it has to be said at the
outset, that most of them
were men who actually created
the physical links that
bind this country together.
And looking at this list, which
was 100 and 120-odd people,
many of them well known, but
most of them very little known,
how to organize it?
Yes, of course, it could
have been alphabetical order.
That would have been
just like looking
through an encyclopedia.
[INAUDIBLE]
It could have been in a
chronological order, which
does have a sort of
narrative logic to it.
But their achievements
and their interests
were all over the map.
And so the reader would be
reading of a 19th century
person involved in
electricity and then
another one involved
in canal making
and would find the same
thing in the 20th century.
So that would be
very, very confusing.
And so one day, I was writing
to a friend of mine in China.
And I had lived in
China for a long while.
And he was reminding me
about Eastern philosophies,
essentially all
those east of India,
where I'd also
lived for a while,
having at the base of many of
their philosophical beliefs
four or five classical elements,
and particularly in China.
And these elements
sort of underpin
everything and the interaction
between these elements.
And they're wood, earth,
water, fire, and metal.
And it suddenly seemed to
me, looking at these five
categories and looking at
this list of 120 names,
that you could actually and
quite logically and quite
reasonably shoehorn these
names into these categories
and it would all sort of work.
So all the early explorers,
because they were essentially
hacking their way
through forests,
they were in birch
bark and wooden canoes,
they were building palisades
of wood to protect themselves,
they were burning log fires
to keep away the wolves,
and so forth, you could say
early American explorers could
be put under a rubric of "wood."
And similarly, once the
country, as the extent
had been defined by these early
explorers, of whom, of course,
Lewis and Clark were
the most famous--
ANDREW LITTELL: Sure.
SIMON WINCHESTER: --then it
would be the early geologists
and surveyors, who
were trying to work out
what America was made of.
Well, that's all
to do with earth,
because the geologists
and rock hounds,
hitting things with hammers and
examining through a magnifying
glass.
So "earth" seemed to
they cover those people
and those achievements.
And then water, the third
of these elements-- well,
the early explorers,
the early settlers
would, if not exploring it,
venturing into the country,
they would do so in the
rivers, the Rappahannock,
and the James, and the
Susquehanna, and the Potomac,
and the Hudson.
And that when they got to
about 50 or 60 miles upstream,
they suddenly found that
they couldn't go any further,
because there was a
line of waterfalls,
because that's where
the Appalachians became
the coastal plain.
And so they settled there,
initially in settlements
that would eventually evolve
into places like Richmond,
and Fredericksburg, and
Washington, DC, and Albany.
And then they
would begin trading
with people, perhaps
upstream of them.
And to get around
the rapids, they
would build very
primitive canals.
And once they learned
how to do that,
then they would build canals
elsewhere in the country,
and famous ones like
the Manchester Canal,
which effectively gave birth
to Boston as a major mercantile
center and the Erie
Canal, the most famous
of all, which essentially made
New York a mercantile center.
So that all worked under
the rubric of "water."
And then fire, well,
it seemed to me
that it was all
very well to travel
behind a horse on a canal.
But that's not very rapidly
crossing the country.
And America, in the 1850s and
1860s, it was picking up speed.
Speed was a necessary possibly
of commerce and moving people
hither and yon.
And this had coincided
with James Watts'
invention of the steam engine.
And so suddenly,
fire-based machinery
was brought into play,
to drive initially
railway trains, and
then early cars.
And then other
forms of fire were
used to power the internal
combustion engine.
And so we get roads,
and we get highways,
and then we get airplanes.
So that all worked under
the rubric of "fire.
And then the fifth and final
of these Chinese classical
elements was "metal."
And that seemed to me was the
metal of the telegraph wire,
and the metal of
electricity distribution.
And then of the
telephone, and then radio,
and then television,
and then what
we're doing today, all the
internet and everything
that Google stands for.
So it did seem that these
five categories not only
worked, but also
where themselves
in chronological order
because wood comes earth,
comes before water.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
It's nice too that it
does fall in somewhat
chronological order.
But you don't feel
confined to-- it's
not like at the beginning
of each section,
it's a certain set
of years necessarily.
There's a ballpark.
But you don't confine
yourself to say, well,
I can't talk about
airplanes in this chapter
because we haven't
gotten there yet.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
I mean someone else, reasonably
the other day, well, there
is the sixth element,
which is occasionally
brought into play,
which is "air."
So why didn't you talk
about airplanes and air?
As I said well, this book,
this is 150,000 word book.
I mean America is
a gigantic subject.
I could have put a
sixth category in.
But my editor, I think he
were saying, wait a minute.
ANDREW LITTELL: It's
got a nice length to it.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
It's got heft to it.
So we don't want to turn it
into an encyclopedia or a Sears
catalog, right?
ANDREW LITTELL: Well, I
thought it was a really--
I mean it allows
you as a writer I
think to try new things as well.
It gives you a construct
in which to work in.
But really let you take
your imagination, which
perhaps as a historian,
and you might not
get to use as much as--
SIMON WINCHESTER: Right.
I mean I must say, I
think of all the books
I've done recently,
this was the most fun.
I was initially thinking
how will Americans--
but then I'm an American--
ANDREW LITTELL: Right.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
-- so I join you--
feel about being examined
through the prism of Chinese
philosophy?
But it's not really.
Because these five elements
are essential really
to all of our lives.
It's not that it's just the
Chinese had classified things
like that, as you said,
two millennia ago.
ANDREW LITTELL: Switching
topics slightly,
the publication of
your book almost
coincided with the shutdown
of the US government.
It happened a couple
weeks later I think.
I'd love to hear-- without
getting too political--
SIMON WINCHESTER: Exactly.
I'm well aware of
that, very hard to.
ANDREW LITTELL: I'd love
to hear your thoughts,
not only as someone who has
just written about uniting
the states, but also
as a newly minted--
I know it's 2011 I think--
SIMON WINCHESTER: It still
feels pretty new to me.
ANDREW LITTELL: --but as a
newly minted American citizen,
your thoughts on that process.
And I think it
strikes some of us
as exactly contradictory to
what you highlight in your book.
SIMON WINCHESTER: It
has a lot of people.
So I mean this too began when
the shutdown was going on.
And they would say,
how on earth can you
write a book called "The
Men Who United the States,"
when the United States is
so apparently disunited?
Well, I mean I had a number
of things to say about that.
I think America is a great deal
better than her politicians,
quite honestly.
ANDREW LITTELL: This might
be true around Google.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Right.
But America has survived a lot
of extraordinary and terrible
national experiences, I
mean not least of course
the Civil War in 1860s.
And yet America
bounced back from that
and it took a long time.
But it survived.
And the guiding
principles of this country
survived Lincoln's
assassination.
It survived the
Great Depression.
It survived lunacies
like Prohibition,
I mean for God's sake.
I don't want to offend
any die-hard people that
are temperance adherents.
But it seems pretty
astonishing to me
that that could be
not only legislation,
but in the Constitution,
that you're not
allowed to buy or liquor.
It survived the Dust Bowl.
It survived, as I
said, the Depression.
It survived Millard Fillmore,
the Know-Nothing party,
all sorts of extraordinary
political parties
and subparties.
And it survived 9/11.
As a nation, it survived
and recovered itself.
It's surviving, it seems,
the current recession,
which we're climbing out of.
And it will survive
the nonsense that
seems to be going on in
Washington these days.
This is just aberrant behavior.
And America just sort
of shrugs it off.
Is wounded by it,
but bounces back.
And that's one of
the things that I so
like about this country, that
nonetheless it dusts itself
off, and thought, well,
that was pretty idiotic.
But I have to say that-- I mean
one of the things that I go on
about in the second part of the
book is the early geologists.
And there are four great
surveys in the 1860s.
And two of the were a man called
Hayden, who essentially mapped
Yellowstone, and John Wesley
Powell, who despite only having
one arm, the earlier
one being shot off
in the battle of Shiloh--
ANDREW LITTELL: Amazing story.
SIMON WINCHESTER: --mapped and
went down the Grand Canyon.
Those two, I think,
great heroes of mine,
would have been
spinning in their graves
I think if they knew that the
national parks that they had
essentially discovered,
Yellowstone and the Grand
Canyon, were shut down, that
the public couldn't see them
because of some trivial
ideological dispute
in Washington, DC.
I think they would have
thought that was madness.
But we survived it nonetheless.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
It was interesting
reading this book,
just having come out
of that experience.
And you only hope that the
wonderful characters, both
known and somewhat
forgotten I would say,
might serve as a reference
point for some of our--
SIMON WINCHESTER: Right.
I don't know-- the
one political point
that sort of shines out of one
of the chapters of this book
relates to, well,
big government.
I mean big government is
very important in this book,
as perhaps we can talk about.
But if I could just talk
about one little thing,
which was rural electrification.
I mean in the fifth part,
which is devoted in part to how
electricity was brought to the
farms in America in the 1930s,
there was a British-- and I
say this wearing my former hat
as a Britain-- so a man called
Samuel Insull, who essentially
controlled most of the
Midwestern electric utility
companies in the 1930s.
And he thought it was a
complete waste of time,
and more importantly
a waste of money,
to wire the farms in
the middle of America
They're expensive beyond belief
to string poles and copper
wire to them.
And yet, the farms-- there
were 800,000 of them,
and producing food at an
enormous pace because America
was getting hungry
and more prosperous.
But they were left
without electricity.
Well, Roosevelt, when he
came to power in the 1930s
and had this gigantic government
apparatus, one aspect of it
was the REA, the Rural
Electrification Administration.
And the stories of how
it brought electric power
to people, I think they're
wonderfully touching stories--
the night the lights came
on in rural communities
all over America.
But the political
point that I think
is worth making is that first
community in America to benefit
from FDR's rural electrification
was in Western Ohio,
in 1935, a little town called
Miami, Ohio-- actually,
a little town
outside Miami-- where
the farms got electricity.
They were the first
ones in the country
to feel the largesse of
the federal government
at its biggest.
Well, that town is in the 8th
congressional district in Ohio,
which is a congressional
district represented
in Congress today
by John Boehner.
So John Boehner, the man
who is the archetype foe
of big government, his
people benefited mightily
from the biggest big government
America has ever known.
So take that, Mr.
Boehner, I want to say.
AUDIENCE: ANDREW LITTELL:
And as a citizen and a voter,
I am sure that you can
take actual action.
SIMON WINCHESTER: I would
like to write to him
and say-- but unfortunately,
I don't live in Miami, Ohio.
ANDREW LITTELL: Of Ohio, yeah.
But it is interesting
to think about-- I
mean from Lewis and
Clark, who were funded
by Thomas Jefferson
and the government,
to the Transcontinental
Railroad,
to the electrical projects of
the Depression, so much of that
was, if not completely
funded, it was certainly
driven by big government.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
But it also-- I
mean this sort of is about the
professions that the two of us
are in today.
The guidebooks
that I took with me
when I visited-- because
I must have visited I
think all of the states,
the contiguous 48
anyway, to do research
for this book--
I collected all
of the WPA guides
that had been made in
the 1930s because they
were stellar pieces
of literature.
You get the guide for Iowa
or the guide for Oregon,
made in the 1930s
and the early 1940s,
financed by the
government, to give work
to unemployed writers,
and photographers,
and editors, who were all out
of work because of the Great
Depression.
And you get the
California guide,
which has essays on California
written by John Steinbeck, who
didn't have work at the time
and accepted a government check.
So I mean that's--
I, believe you me,
despite coming from Britain and
despite "socialized medicine"
and all those things which
we're supposed to have,
I think government needs
to be controlled of course.
But when government works
well-- the REA, the WPA guides,
the Boulder Dam, the
Tennessee Valley Authority,
the Moon shot-- government
can be extremely effective.
And it shouldn't in my view
be tossed overboard in the way
that some politicians
are threatening to do.
ANDREW LITTELL: Well, it
be interesting to see how
the next couple
months in Washington--
SIMON WINCHESTER:
It will indeed.
ANDREW LITTELL:
I do want to make
sure we get to Google and
the internet and your opinion
there.
But I would like to talk a
little bit about geology.
And you were a geology major
at university, I believe?
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
ANDREW LITTELL: And I
think you were a geologist
by trade for a few years--
SIMON WINCHESTER:
For a year, yes.
ANDREW LITTELL: --before
coming into journalism.
It's been wonderful to see the
books that you've written over,
at last the past
couple of years,
have this very passionate focus
on what's beneath the surface
and beneath the Earth.
And some of the most
interesting characters
I think that came
out of this book
were some of the old geologists,
the original geologists
for the United States.
So I'm interested in what
appealed to you originally
about geology and
how you maintain
that interest in the
science over the past years?
SIMON WINCHESTER: I
wish I could tell you
that my entry into
geology was because
of a passionate schoolboy
love of ammonites or rocks.
But it wasn't.
I initially wanted
to be a sailor.
I wanted to wander
around the world.
And I took all my
exams and everything
to go to Dartmouth, which is
the equivalent of Annapolis
in Britain, and
passed all the exams,
until I came to do the medical.
And then, he showed
me, the doctor,
a loose leaf book with
circles, with dots on it.
And he said, what number
do you see in that circle?
And I said 47.
And he looked at me and
he said, are you serious?
And I said yes.
He suddenly turned
to another one,
they were red, green, and
blue dots and I said 23.
And he shut the book with
this terrible finality
and said, Mr.
Winchester, I'm terribly
sorry to have to tell you
that Her Majesty, the Queen,
takes a rather
dim view of people
driving her very expensive
warships around the world who
can't tell red from green,
and therefore left from right.
So I'm afraid
another career will--
So then there was an
advert-- in the school, sort
of career's office, there was
a picture of a man in shorts,
with a hammer, standing on
some mountain in Africa saying,
see the world, be a geologist.
And I thought well, if I
can't tell red from green,
maybe I can tell ammonites
from graptolites.
And so I took an O-level, which
is an exam you take at 16,
and passed it.
And then went up to
Oxford to study it.
And loved it, but wasn't
terribly good at it.
And so was shipped off
to Uganda and worked
in the mountains between Uganda
and Congo, looking for copper.
Didn't find a
microgram of copper.
And then worked on an oil rig
in the North Sea for a while.
And actually did quite a lot
of-- it was gas in those days.
But then, through a
rather complicated set
of circumstances,
drifted away from geology
and into journalism.
But still have this
affection for the science
and so write about
it whenever I can.
ANDREW LITTELL: And it's
nice that now that you're
able to perhaps select
the topics that you'd
like to write about, you
can return to those roots
as it were.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Well, and indeed,
the book I'm working on
now is quite a big book
about the Pacific Ocean.
And there's heaps
of geology there
because there's the
whole ring of fire.
And so I'll have
great fun with that.
ANDREW LITTELL: That's nice.
So you've gone
from the Atlantic,
to focusing on the continental--
SIMON WINCHESTER: US, yeah.
ANDREW LITTELL: And
now on to the Pacific.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Well,
HarperCollins, my publishers,
who I'm enormously fond of, of
course, I keep saying trilogy,
trilogy, trilogy.
Whether it will ever a be
boxed set, I don't know.
But it does seem to
have a logic to it--
ANDREW LITTELL: It does.
Yeah.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
--Atlantic America, Pacific.
We'll see.
ANDREW LITTELL: So you
end the book by discussing
the internet, and
its power to connect
not only the US, but also
the world, whether as a dream
or as a nightmare.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
And incidentally, I should
say that of the one the places
that I lingered at, but
wasn't able to get into,
was Council Bluffs in Iowa,
where the old drive-in movie
theater is now a great
big Google server farm.
Very impressive, I must say.
I went to server farms.
But Google was rather
private about their own.
So--
ANDREW LITTELL: Too many.
SIMON WINCHESTER: --I
stood outside, like a boy,
sort of in a zoo,
and looked through.
But I think I know more
or less what's in there.
But yes, the thing that
I think interests me
about whether the internet is a
unifying thing or not, I think
goes back to my
feelings about radio.
I think radio is the great
national and cultural unifier,
the image you have of the
walnut-paneled behemoth
in the living room, with the
family gathered around it,
mother, father, children,
dogs, cats, all listening
to a program that's the NBC
Symphony Orchestra being beamed
in from New York City, or
a comedy program coming in
from Los Angeles, or a drama
being sent down from Chicago,
is an image both of
sort of national unity
and also familial unity.
But then came television,
which preserved this unity
for a while.
Everyone watched Johnny Carson.
Everyone watch Jack Paar.
But then came cable television.
And cable television,
which came about initially
in West Virginia in
the 1970s, then had,
and unconsciously at first,
it started dividing people.
So that dad was in
the den watching ESPN.
And mom, I don't want
to be sexist about this,
was watching another
kind of program.
And then soon, the
internet exacerbated this.
And everyone in the family
was doing something different.
Seldom now, unless they're
big news events, like the Moon
landing, or 9/11, or the
killing of a president,
few electronically transmitted
events bring everyone together.
They tend to divide people into
their little interest groups.
And I'm afraid, with
my belief that unity
in a country like this
is terribly important,
that splitting it into
intellectual subgroups,
which is something the
internet seems to be doing,
is inimical to that
basically, idea.
I think society
will deal with it.
But at the moment, I think
it's an open question
as to how it will deal with it.
So, of course, I think
the internet is wonderful.
But I think it has social
aspects to disunity,
which are somewhat troubling.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
And it's interesting to think
about-- I mean all of your book
focuses on unifying the US,
where the internet is certainly
a more global phenomenon.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Well, certainly.
Yeah.
ANDREW LITTELL: Being able
to-- if the railroad started,
the US was the first country
with a transcontinental
railroad and being able to
explain that to the world.
There's certainly
some parallels there.
But the internet I think is
the first mode to be able to--
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Expand the world.
ANDREW LITTELL:
--expand the world.
Which is-- in some
ways I agree with you--
which is a frightening, but
also very liberating idea.
SIMON WINCHESTER: It is.
And if I'm silent,
it's just that I
don't know how to deal with it.
It's a social enigma
to me at the moment.
And the experience of cable
television and the internet
in dealing with
the United States
tends to run counter to my hope
and thesis that's in the book.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yup.
SIMON WINCHESTER: But as
I say, this book I think,
and I hope you feel
it, radiates optimism.
ANDREW LITTELL: Definitely.
SIMON WINCHESTER: The
fact that the country
has survived all these ills
and come up smiling every time.
I'm not saying the
internet is an ill,
but I think the country--
society-- will deal with it
in a sensible and pragmatic way.
ANDREW LITTELL:
And in the same way
that-- I mean when
radio first came out,
there were tons of fears about
what this influence could
be on the hitherto other-- or
uneducated populace of the US.
And did you want that
demon box sitting
in your living room
speaking to you?
And so I see similar reactions
to other previous mass
communication inventions.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
I mean almost
everything is in this--
I mean starting with the
telegraph and Samuel Morse's
invention, everyone
was hostile initially.
I mean look at the
trouble that Morse
had to get Congress to agree
to any kind of experiment,
any kind of funding for it.
But then of course,
suddenly, they
embraced it and
realized what Morse
had realized for some years.
So many of these people are
people pounding on the door
and saying look, believe me,
this is a great, great idea.
But it's interesting, of course,
that the internet grew out
of the government
sponsored idea.
The ARPAnet after all
was a government idea.
I wonder whether it would
ruin the technology here
to play you the
first-- I don't it
will-- the first
voice that was ever
transmitted over the radio.
Because getting back
to what we were talking
about a few moments ago
about how the radio is
a great unifying medium, well,
of course, when radio was
invented, it was all Morse code.
What Marconi sent and
received from Signal Hill
in Newfoundland was Morse.
But it took this extraordinary
and forgotten man
called Reginald Fessenden
to come up with AM and FM,
that we know all about, a
wonderful name, Reginald Aubrey
Fessenden.
And he was the first person
ever to broadcast human voice
over the radio, which began
the national conversation.
And this was the voice.
And I think I got to queued up.
So if I'm anywhere
near the microphone,
I think you should
be able to hear it.
And this was sent
out to all the ships
at sea working for the
United Fruit Company.
He send a message by Morse, just
before Christmas, 1906, telling
these operators to
listen out at one minute
at midnight on Christmas
Eve, for a special broadcast.
And so it happened to be
a dark and stormy night.
And off Cape Cod, there was
a huge blizzard blowing.
And the ships that were
bringing bananas up
from places like
Juticalpa in Honduras,
to Boston, and Baltimore,
and New York City,
tuned in their
radios and listened
through the static and the
Morse chatter of other ships.
But instead of
Morse, they had this.
[MUSIC, EMMI LEISNER,
"OMBR MAI FU"]
Now, that's a singer
called Emmi Leisner,
singing "Ombr mai fu," which
has nothing to do with America.
It's all to do with a Persian
king and a shade tree.
And after that was over,
then Fessenden himself,
who was a big, burly man,
with a wonderful bass voice,
came and said the Lord's Prayer.
And then said a very happy
Christmas to you all.
And the first voice broadcast,
ever broadcast to the public,
ended.
But within a week,
over in Pasadena,
a radio station opened above
Sherman's, a musical instrument
store, which still exists,
selling-- or playing music.
And then three months,
are a cornfield
in Madison, Wisconsin,
an area was built,
and the first ever
radio station,
which became WHA,
which still exists.
And then the national
conversation began.
But I love the thought that
that beautiful piece of music
was the beginning
of the conversation,
all to do with bananas as well.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
And that story
right there is one
of the things that also
appealed to me about the book
is that you intersperse within a
lot of the biography or history
parts, your own personal
experiences of visiting
some of these places.
At first, reading
the first person
in a nonfiction book
or a history book
sometimes can have
a jarring effect.
But I found this to
be very, very natural.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Well, thank you.
ANDREW LITTELL: And being able
to visualize those places today
I thought was a
fascinating look at how
we've forgotten
some of these very
important markers for example.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
One of the journeys
that I really enjoyed for
this book was discovering
the origins of the
interstate highway system.
Conventionally, we believe
it's known as the Eisenhower
system of interstate
and defense highways
because Eisenhower saw the
autobahns in Germany in 1945.
Well, he did.
But that's not the reason
the system has got that name.
It's because he was an
observer, as a young major,
on an expedition run
by the Army in 1919,
to cross the country in military
vehicles from the South Lawn
of the White House
to San Francisco,
as rapidly as
possible, to thwart
a theoretical Japanese
invasion of California.
The generals at the
National War College thought
what if the Japanese, who were
getting somewhat restless,
even prior to the
last century, what
would happen if they
invaded California?
How quickly could we get troops
from the big bases in the East,
by road, across to
defend the West Coast.
So they assembled this convoy,
about three miles long,
of tanks, and armored vehicles,
and commissary wagons,
and hospitals, and
jeeps, and things,
with the young-- he's in
his 20s-- Major Eisenhower,
as an observer, and
to keep a diary.
It was a complete shambles.
I mean it took 58 days.
They went an average speed
of six miles an hour.
And believe you me, if
the Japanese had invaded,
they would have swallowed
up California, and Arizona,
and New Mexico, and
probably, and possibly
for the benefit of us all, would
have taken most of West Texas
as well.
But Eisenhower's diary--
I got a copy of it,
thanks to the
internet, of course--
and decided to follow and
go to each of the places
that these soldiers had been on.
And one of them
was a place that I
had wanted to go to since
I was at 15-year-old,
and that was the town
of Dennison, Iowa.
And not too far actually
from the Google complex
in Council Bluffs.
Dennison, I had wanted
to go to because it
was the birthplace of the
woman that I as a 15-year-old,
thought was the most
beautiful woman in the world.
And the Army team had
been there in 1919.
They had played
I think baseball,
had lost to the
citizens of Dennison.
They had watched films in
the Dennison opera house.
I mean how wonderful
that there's
an opera house in a little
town in western Iowa.
But two years later--
completely, obviously,
unconnected with
the soldier's visit,
a child was born
called Donna Mullenger.
And she grew up.
She was wanting to
become a teacher.
But her parents didn't have the
money to send her to school.
And so she got on the Union
Pacific train at Omaha
and went to Hollywood.
Her attractiveness allowed
her to be signed by MGM.
And initially, she was
called Donna Adams.
But because the two As,
didn't allow her name
to be said very easily, they
changed her name to Donna Reed.
And Donna Reed, when I saw that
movie, the "Wonderful Life,"
when she played
Mrs. George Bailey,
I thought she, in
Bedford Falls, was just
the apotheosis of
American beauty.
And so I wanted to go
to where she was born.
And so, I went there.
And the old opera house is now
the Donna Reed Performing Art
Center.
And the Oscar she won for
"From Here to Eternity,"--
she, for some
reason, didn't win it
for "It's a Wonderful
Life"-- is there.
And Fat Mo's in Chicago
had donated a soda fountain
counter.
So that's there, which
is where young George
Bailey got hit in the ear.
So you remember, he was deaf
in the movie or half deaf.
But the extraordinary
thing about it
is that attractive
a town though it
may be, it absolutely stinks.
And it stinks because two miles
away, to the west of the town,
is a gigantic feedlot, in which
200,000 cattle are standing
all the time, providing beef for
the hungry people of the East
Coast.
But when the wind is
in the wrong direction,
this terrible miasma of cattle
and with all their products,
sweeps over Dennison and
makes it less beautiful
place that I
Imagined it would be.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean I think-- and I see this
through many of your books--
is you're more of a storyteller
I see than a historian.
And there's such easy
books to read I find,
not to make it too simple.
But, they're so engaging.
And its stories like
that I think move you
through the book.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Well, it's
very nice for you to say.
But I'm pleased that the reviews
thus far, a number of them
have been by academics.
And then I'm always wary
and thinking academics
might not like a
book that is, as you
say, more stories than
perhaps classical history.
But, they've said nice things.
ANDREW LITTELL: So
you've very productive.
And since-- I guess I look
at 1998, when you really
started being an author
full time, let's say.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Yes.
ANDREW LITTELL:
10 books, I think
in 15 years and five "New
York Times" best sellers.
So we at Google have certainly
looked at a lot of metrics
and done a lot of research
on how productive people are.
SIMON WINCHESTER: I'm
now getting terrified
about what you're
going to tell me.
ANDREW LITTELL: We've
certainly looked
at what makes people
productive, and not
only quality, but quantity.
Any tips that you
can provide on how
to maintain such a high
level of work, but certainly
have been so productive
over the past?
SIMON WINCHESTER: Well, I
remember when I was small,
my father's the preferred
newspaper in our house
was "The Daily Telegraph."
And they ran an
advertisement every day,
I think on the front page, for
some course called Pelmanism.
I have no idea
what Pelmanism was.
But the question at the top was,
do you have a grasshopper mind?
If you have a grasshopper
mind, then you
should take a
course in Pelmanism.
My father had threatening.
He said, you just
keep-- everything's
all over the map with you.
You're going to be a dilettante.
You're going to know
nothing at all well.
I'm going to sign up for
a course on Pelmanism.
And I'm jolly glad he didn't.
So my first piece
of advice is do not
take a course on Pelmanism.
ANDREW LITTELL: Right.
SIMON WINCHESTER: But, no.
And I think if you're got a
grasshopper mind, encourage it.
But, I mean you've got
to be very focused.
And I think I am.
I live on this farm in
Western Massachusetts.
And I've got a study.
And I just bury myself
away for months at a time
and get it done.
But I love every aspect.
I love the research.
And who wouldn't?
ANDREW LITTELL: And I
know you do all your own--
SIMON WINCHESTER: I do.
ANDREW LITTELL:
--research as well.
SIMON WINCHESTER: And
then the writing is nice.
The editing, when you
have to slash away things
that the editor--
like, "you're not
allowed to put airplanes
in the air" chapter.
In fact, get rid
of the air chapter.
And that's a bit frustrating.
But that aside, the
process is great fun.
So, enjoy it.
ANDREW LITTELL: And
in my imagination,
you have a book of
like 500 book ideas
that you've been collecting
over the past 50 years.
Is that accurate?
You just jot down some--
SIMON WINCHESTER: Sort of.
There are all sorts of
things I want to do.
And now, of course, I'm
just coming up to 70.
There is the feeling
that, you know,
so many books to write and
not enough time to do them.
ANDREW LITTELL: So little time.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
But at least, I've
got three or four sort
of waiting in the wings.
ANDREW LITTELL: Yeah.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
The Pacific is next.
And that's what I'm
concentrating on now, yeah.
ANDREW LITTELL: OK.
Great.
So I would like
to point out one--
I have one part of your
book that I took issue with.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Oh, right.
ANDREW LITTELL: So we're here
at Google's New York office,
in the middle of Manhattan,
state-of-the-art building,
with sun-filled offices
and communal work spaces.
Does being here change
at all your view
of employees at
technology companies?
One of the last
lines of your book
is "The new pioneers
of unification
will be technical men,
hidden quietly out of sight
in their blue-lit
warehouses, surrounded
by silent frenzies of
blinking server lights."
And I'm not sure if we should be
flattered or offended by that.
SIMON WINCHESTER: [INAUDIBLE].
I have been to
your establishment
a number of times now.
I've eaten in your
wonderful cafeteria.
I've ridden on your
Razor scooters.
I've been to Apple.
I've been to-- yes.
The place where the connections,
the connective tissue--
is-- of these cages of servers,
with these silent guardians,
in Mountain View,
and in Cupertino,
and in Council Bluffs,
Iowa-- those are the people
I'm writing about here.
Not the creative
people like myself.
So forgive me.
And in the paperback,
I'll amend it accordingly.
ANDREW LITTELL: No.
No, need to.
And, as we were talking
about before this,
I think there are a lot
of still open questions
that we're working to solve
here, not only here at Google,
but anybody working
in technology.
And information is
a powerful thing.
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Well, if you think
my metrics are
impressive, I think
you metrics are astonishing.
ANDREW LITTELL:
Thank you very much.
If anybody has any
questions from the audience,
feel free to ask them now.
AUDIENCE: As a historian, which
other historians from the past
do you find particularly
interesting?
SIMON WINCHESTER:
Well, oddly enough,
there's an English
historian, who probably you
won't be familiar with,
called Arthur Bryant,
who did a series of books,
the history of Britain
and the history of Europe,
in the 1930s and '40s.
And became wildly popular
because he told history
through human stories.
I mean I like
Mayhew, for instance,
who wrote the history of
London, once again through-- not
through so much through
theses or social movements,
but the history of ordinary
people, and told stories.
Narrative social history
is what I'm interested in.
And those are the kind
of people that I like.
But I mean of course,
David McCullough,
I think is absolutely wonderful.
Plus, he drives the same kind
of Land Rover that I drove,
a nice old Land Rover.
And he lives in Maine.
So he's a good guy, as
far as I'm concerned.
But he's the sort
of chap I like.
And Arthur Bryant,
in the past too.
ANDREW LITTELL: Another
question I had is you've
written about all these
different periods in your book,
here in the US.
If you could return and live
during one of those ages,
do you have a favorite?
SIMON WINCHESTER: I do really.
And expanding this
beyond the United States,
I love the time when there
were polymaths around,
people that knew
everything or that
had an interest in
just about everything
and a huge level of competence.
And my great hero
is James Murray,
the editor of "The Oxford
English Dictionary."
I mean he-- Latin, and Greek,
and chemistry, and physics,
and philosophy, the tendrils
rules of his imagination
spread everywhere.
And there was such people in
the United States, of course.
I mean, Jefferson.
I mean, good god, I mean
what an amazing man Thomas
Jefferson was.
So to live in a
period which fostered
the Jeffersons in
the James Murrays
suggests to me-- because
such people are now
either nonexistent,
or not revered,
or they're just jabbering on
the street corners in Manhattan.
I don't know where they are.
But I'd like to live
in a society-- I'm
very happy to live
nowadays-- but I
would like to
revisit a time when
such people were
cherished and revered.
ANDREW LITTELL: Certainly.
Well, thank you very
much for your time.
SIMON WINCHESTER: Thank
you very much, indeed.
This has been great.
Thank you.